hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts transcription analysis
presented by dr. mark Pearson I wrote
out Albert elbonian professor of
biomedical informatics and co-director
of the Yale computational biology and
bioinformatics program at Yale
University
I am Marjorie Torrance of labs and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to be in this educational
web seminar presented by library
labyrinth is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
performance again I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of this
presentation limit entire question into
the box that appears on the screen
whereas there is many questions we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation and the slides
and mail to a marshal in don't just
click on this green icon located on the
lower left if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
this presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem
this presentation is educational and
that offers continuing educational
credits please click on the button in
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to attain your credits
please join me in welcoming dr. mark
Greene I will now turn the presentation
over to him hello so I'll begin now I'd
like to talk today about transcriptome
analysis and I'm going to talk about
core issues related to transcript
analysis particularly getting it team
regulation and I'm also going to talk
about some things that come about when
you do a large-scale transcriptome
analysis and you should study that
activity itself the data exhaust of
people
mining the transcription surrounded by
that so it's kind of uh sort of meta and
the analysis so first of all I thought
I'd just give you a sense of what you
study when you study the transcriptome
as you all know RNA transcription comes
about from the sort of fundamental
process of reading out what's in genes
in this of course is result of RNA
polymerase producing a transcript and
the transcripts are usually thought to
be either protein coding transcripts
that are going to form protein coding
genes or things related to non-coding
RNAs and people on access a take the
transcripts from these things and cut
them up into little pieces and then
sequence them in next-gen sequencing
machines to get a sense of which
transcripts are present in different
types of cells and cells in different
states and they also can get a sense of
how many there are of a particular
transcript and this gives them the kind
of readout of the activity of different
genes now and this readout it people
usually refer to this whole process is
kind of doing an rna-seq experiment
which is the sort of center expensive
experiment in transcriptomics and I
thought I'd just kind of quickly tell
you of what you get and one of these
experiments I mean the sort of basic and
you get an experiment is use numbers of
sequence wheats and so these are the
whole time
synthesis sequence and they occupy you
know maybe a number of gigabytes and on
copy your experiment did and people then
tend to take each of these reads and map
it back to the genome and usually that
for some sort of reduces the size or the
data files will by
after I show this and then by looking at
how high the stack of a line reads at
any given base they can form comfort
coded signal track which is just you
know how many are NAC reads are aligned
at a given spot on the genome and then
the final thing they do is they tend to
say average the amount of sort of reads
over a given location say over a next
month to get a level of gene expression
or a silent expression and so for not
the sort of final output of one of these
experiments of course as we move down
this process work on reducing the data
and we're talking about stores for
amounts of information so we start off
with you know literally files that have
billions of bins where they have all
these reads and at the end you know we
might end up with a vector of just
20,000 numbers that represented the
level of the 20,000 canonical genes
which they're on ball and that sort of
represents processing of these from so
now what when we think about trying to
analyze these experiments but I have
this metaphor about looking at activity
patterns and you know what you should
see in five nails on a picture of sore
thumb
time-lapse picture of Isis bastards and
you can see the lights going on and off
and you can think of each window is over
Jean and you're you know one second year
doing that cause they're coming from you
seeing how much each key is on or in
this metaphor how much how much
illumination you have in each window of
the building and then you're watching
this over time and you know windows are
going on and off and you're so seeing
the kind of activity of the cell and so
forth and what that's what we could have
observed if we do a number of
transcriptomics programs and the goal in
the kind of analysis to kind of infer
what's going on in the route how are all
these lights that are going on are they
regulated how are they control
you know what's the inner structure
that's controlling them and you know
it's very much like securing out at the
city and you're looking at these
buildings and suddenly a hopeful light
goes on or you know one you know two
lights and two different parts of the
building kind of gone at the same time
because thinking self jeez you know
what's going on they have your
conference on that floor are the two
people leaving new office at the same
time or what what's this mean and it's
the sort of same idea when we're kind of
peering at the cell and we're trying to
understand you know why these jeans
going on walk together you know in this
biological process so that's the sort of
overall thing that we're doing in our
basic analysis and you know there's sort
of some kind of basic questions where
some thinking about you know we often
look at these activity patterns kind of
across different times and all sort of
different sets of samples so one thing
you can of course look at it as an
organism develops you know we can see
the organism developing from say the
embryo the larvae it's an adult you know
what kind of which genes come go on and
off together in development we can also
take maybe the same adult cell in
different organisms but that we know
we're related we can see if those
organisms have similar genes on and off
and so forth you know if we take solve
some bringing princess and say human
Mouse the chimpanzees are similar genes
on or off and so forth we can of course
ask if we look at people getting a
disease you know for instance someone
getting cancer and with repair it's
normal we can see again how to be it has
the activity patterns change are there
certain genes that go on when you get a
particular disease or the circum games
that go off and so forth and then also
we can look at individual variation you
can see if we just take the example of
someone's blood over many individuals
you can
c20 changes in jeans kind of going up
and down that represent really the same
type of cell and an adult but it's
really varying across different people
and the idea here is that that kind of
the variation that you see between
individuals and somehow related to their
underlying on genomic differences so
those are some of the different types of
variation you can see in these
experiments now so that's the kind of
core analysis we're trying to do in one
of these promised but there's also this
idea that we're doing a sort of
large-scale analysis of this data
sometimes we can see other things and we
people often use the term data exhaust
to describe it so we're doing an
activity like this a consortium that
collecting a lot of information about
transcriptomes and so forth and we can
actually study that activity itself the
activity of collecting all that day or
what it says about the consortium or
what we're going to also talk about is
how when we're collecting all these DNA
sequence we'd say related to cancer or
related to certain cell types we
actually inadvertently reveal a lot
about the underlying subject or person
being studied and again that's an aspect
of this kind of um inter inadvertent
data collection that exhaust of the
process and we'll talk about that too
so now I what you see it was outline for
this talk and so first we're going to
talk about the kind of core things that
happen entrusted some analysis and you
know mining the activity gene so we're
going to talk about you know how we
cluster them together how we can kind of
build models that I talked about which
genes tend to work together and how
they're controlled and then we finally
talk about trying to simplify those
models into kind of a very circuit like
a logic gate type of description of the
transcriptome and that's the kind of
core analysis raz
then I'm going to talk about well you
know people are doing these RNA T
experiments on lots of people there's
also this issue that you know we are
getting weeds and levels of genes
lots of individuals and actually there's
a serious privacy concern I'm going to
talk about those concerns and how sort
of think about them and in particular
how we can think about it non amaizing
the RNA seek data sets and so forth and
then I'm also going to finally talk a
little about this more about this of
data exhaust issues and this idea that
well actually look at these big groups
of people that generate all this data
they you know they generate a lot of
papers they work together they have an
activity pattern and not actually kind
of in this house it's also interesting
to say and we can see some interesting
relationships between people and how
datasets are disseminated so we'll talk
about that at the end so now let's go on
to the first of the three topics which
is really core gene expression so first
we're going to focus on a very basic
science thing we're going to look at
gene expression and development and
we're going to look at gene expression
data from the encode project and so the
end of project this big genome
annotation project is mostly focused on
the patent human genome but they've also
developed a lot of functional genomics
data sets for model organisms such as
the worm the fly and also the mouse and
we you know the consortium is tried to
kind of put them together a little bit
in register with the human data and one
of the nice things from our against
terms of courses we can look at the gene
expression throughout the life stage you
know an embryo as the organism develops
and you know we can't do that so he's
really filed for a human and that gives
us really a sense of you know certain
genes that may be important in very
early life states that we don't see in a
dolphin
the nice thing also looking at multiple
model misses we can of course impair
limit so we have these really nice data
sets for the warm of the thigh that are
sort of diagram to some degree circles
here that should look at the entire dock
from embryo to larva
and then in the quad there's additional
space for pupae and you end up with the
ducts and we have these I did says there
they're roughly about thirty some-odd
stages for both the one on the fly you
know they're collected over this develop
and there's also a lot sort of problem
additional data sets they have data sets
in of you and now these aren't over
development but some of them you can
also kind of put in register with the
owner by this and so we're gonna be
talking about so the first thing we
might want to do cuz analytically is we
might want to ask which genes go on and
off together and develop maybe there's
some genes that come on early and make a
lot later on together and so forth and
this is the kind of canonical problem of
gene expression clustering this was
originally tackled about twenty years
ago when people started doing gene
expression experiments and there's been
many algorithms be looked at all for
clustering gene expression there's all
sorts of ways to disassemble our cluster
anything dimensionality reduction
algorithms and all sorts of things but
one of the things that we started to
think about well we're actually
interested in doing clustering in a
number of different audiences we'd like
to kind of cluster the gene expression
in a human but we'd also like to do it
in the women the fly we like to cluster
them all together maybe there's a way of
doing the clustering so that it's kind
of solved assistant and so to do that we
use this idea that there's often this
concept of orthotics
that are essentially the equivalent
genes between two species and we want to
kind of cluster the to say two organisms
so that there are bollocky students kind
of get placed in a similar way into
clusters on jobs an algorithm called
ortho plus so to do this in this
algorithm dissolves the cross species
modules and two expressions and the
algorithm uses this concept of network
modularity and you know have a
complicated formula here
what the formula is going to measure is
how well cluster treatment so let me
explain that concept so if you look at
the top there's two networks there's a
dolphin social network in the political
books Network and they're the nodes are
colored you know two different colors
networking you can sort of see in the
dolphin network that coloring is it
makes more sense to serve two groups and
they're really not connected that well
whereas one on the political looks
network but even though we've colored
things different cause they're less
separated and so we can measure this
degree to which the labeling and the
clustering really affects to true
separateness between things by using
this concept of network modularity this
is a concept that was induced by human
of years ago and basically what you do
in this thing is you compare it for a
given cluster which is something that
would be colored something you compare
how many connections there are between
things in the same module with the
number that you expect from random
chance so that's the that that's the
number of things that you um that are
connected are in the adjacency matrix
and the number expected firmness charm
that has had some case of on occasion J
over 2m and if they're in the same
module or not count them as they're is
based on this Delta and so this just
kind of shows you if you sort of label
your nose in a way that doesn't really
reflect the underlying modularity you'll
get a very low value for this money
whereas if you label your notes here in
a way that really does reflect the
underlying structure you'll get a very
high value or maximum values to the
modifier and so what you might want to
do in Kuster is you I want to try to
some eyes that I thought you might want
to color your nose in such a way to
nationalize it and that's of course
would give you an optimal clustering say
one species and what we introduced this
notion of doing this clustering problem
simultaneously in two different species
and we demand that the labels are
consistently colored in the two
different species Institute have two
genes of or plots so we add so we
maximize a modularity and say organism a
we maximize the modular an organism B
but the key thing is we also add in a
third term that we provide a reward if
the coloring essentially of the
clustering is the same in the two
different organisms and that's that sort
of third term in equalness um and and so
with that we can develop this notion of
things that clusters that just having
one species pluses that you have any
other species but the key things you
have clusters that are really
consistently label they're both species
now you can do this and you can muster
any number of species and here I
actually show a clustering that we
developed a number of years ago for
human warmest bot and so you can see on
this picture there are some groups of
genes that you you can see they
clustered together say for instance just
in worm that would be say the pentagonal
group or they may be say clustered
together in worm and fly and that's the
star group but then you can see there's
groups that they're connected in warm
blood human and that's the circle group
and those are these kind very conserved
models and overall we found 16 is sort
of modeled by represent genes that tend
to go on and off together
in a consistent fashion in human worm
recline these are organisms that are
separated by hundreds of years of
history but they represent some very
ancient patterns of gene expression
and one of the things that we found was
that a lot of these modules that
represent the sage encounters they have
a particular type of gene expression
called the hourglass taker which people
think is very important in development
where they have a very constrained gene
expression during a period of
embryogenesis and so we felt that these
these modules represent very ancient
developmental programs approaching
community but these modules were
important in that way okay so now I'm
going to go on to the next section
state-space models so so we have this
notion that we've introduced to having
these chip and species we have this
notion of these gene expression clusters
in each species and then we have the
notion of for many of the genes that
have this pathologist relationship
between two solutions and some genes
however we have decided that they're
maybe not or thought there are some how
species incident and if we look at one
of our connect assertive clusters you
might want to ask can you think of the
dynamics of the dog the up and down of
these genes or the activities genes as
being controlled just within the third
module or do you have to evoke some
genes that are species specific to think
on to describe that and so to answer
that question we sort of use this
formalism of kind of a state based model
so we have this notion that our internal
group of genes we have the notion of
somehow for the gene expression level
one gene it could be related to the gene
expression levels of many of the genes
in each R group but we also have the
external group and we we can ask to what
degree do we need to invoke that
external group to explain gene
expression control group and it's sort
of very much like if you think about
like that a dynamical system like a
spring system you can talk about the
dynamics of that system internally to
the spring or you
kind of evoke this notion of some sort
of external force or a driving force
that affects the dynamics of the of the
system so how do we mathematically
actually carry out this state space
modeling well the way we do it is we
describe the state of a self of state of
systems as a vector we call X and the
vector has all the genes in say the tour
group and that's that sort of green
column vector that we describe as a team
and that's the state of the level of
gene expression of all the genes so we
can think of the internal dynamics as
that state s of T evolving to X of T
plus 1 and the 1 way of thinking about
that evolution is to think about the
levels as I said T of one somehow being
some linear combination water levels of
X 14 that describes in an abstract way
all the genes within the internal group
determining the pattern of the next day
and if you had a system that was purely
driven by internal dynamics that's all I
need but you can also think that the
level that X of T plus 1 also depend on
external factors and we denote that as
use of T and so and we can think of the
couple inducing the external factors and
X of T is being through this what's
called the B matrix which captures the
coupling between use of T and X of T
plus 1 and so we can write this in a
sort of canonical so state-based type of
thing where we can write it as matrices
here except see this one is a X of T of
the routine now in theory we can figure
out all the parameters for this matrix a
if we had an infinite number of gene
expression measurements and so forth we
could do this incidence we don't have
enough data points to determine all
those
rameters and so one of the things we
realized that we could do those we could
reduce the dimensionality of the system
and to reduce the dimensionality of the
system what we did is we took the matrix
a and we surrend singular value
conscious or dimensionality reduction
and just we expressed it in terms of its
main kind of associate crucible
coordinates you know just sort of the
five leading eigenvectors of that matrix
and now what we can do is we can express
each gene in X of T on the projection
onto those buy vectors and that gives us
a kind of reduced dimensionality picture
of the system and then we describe the
reduced dimensionality picture the
system is X hat or tilde of T so now if
X of T was 5,000 X tilde T might be fine
you know there might be able to five
metagenes okay that describes the main
types of genes going up and down and now
we of course have reduced the number of
parameters on a system dramatically and
we can try to get at trying to determine
the values of the a matrix and the B
measures now to do that what we do is we
die by the a matrix and we describe the
the a matrix as a sort of in terms of
what's called internal dynamic pattern
called IPP sorry I PD P where lambda P
is the Keith eigen value of n so it we
we describe the dynamics of the a matrix
in terms of
on time exponential of these so see
these patterns have kind of
characteristic I think they tend to rise
they tend to fall they tend to oscillate
and they represent kind of canonical
dynamical behaviors of this matrix so so
now we can kind of describe an overall
workflow where we start off with our
gene expression system we have our
internal on genes they have connections
we have our external drivers we describe
them in these matrices we reduce the
matrices now to these metagenes now we
have smaller number of variables and we
have R on the meta means have an
internal dynamics and there also have an
external dynamics in this reduced space
then what we do is we figure out our
into PPP's our internal dynamic patterns
we can also figure out our DP DP
external patterns in this reduced
dimensional space and then finally we
project these back into the higher space
and we describe each of our original
genes in some linear combination of
these internal dynamic patterns and so
now let me see my table what's the focus
and I think the point of it you can see
a little more when you get the results
so if we take the worm developmental
time course in the Flies not much one
first we can take the the you know the
lavanya's genes that are common to the
worm of life we can determine the meta
genes related to each of those so we can
figure out the internal dynamic patterns
nuts what's shown in the left hand side
of the figure and you can see that this
sort of four leading intro guy McAdams
one is kind of a sort of flat and then
starts update more once a full one as
arise was this muscle engine and one
thing that's really amazing
is that you can see that the internal
venom powers both the worm advise
development are very similar
they're extremely similar for one's not
the same but they're fairly similar now
we can do the same thing for the
external platters and you can see the
external planners they are very little
relationship between the one we'll apply
and what's amazing is that these
internal patterns are developed in
isolation of each other we don't inform
the word patterns by the five patterns
or vice-versa yet they at the end look
very similar and was also shown the next
figures if I just simply took if I
showed you the top five leading managing
patterns for the worm and the five
that's what I show now in the green
boxes in this figure you can see they
have very little relationship to each
other I mean there's some similar to
each other and you can see how the
internal dynamic patterns are much more
so much somehow they capture a truly
ancient mode of activity that you don't
see you directly look at patterns now
then the next thing we can do is we can
say for for any given gene in the worm
of the fly what it's projection onto one
of these canonical patterns and so and
we can ask for a given gene in the worm
and the fly to have a similar projection
onto the two onto these patterns and one
thing you can see is that there's a
tremendous correlation between the worm
and the fly I'll change the
ornithologist genes that have fairly
similar Erlik related projections on
these types of fairly high our
correlation coefficients and then what
you can also see is that the projections
are considerably higher or you think
ancient conservative jeans like
ribosomal genes versus a younger and
more diverging such as genes related to
signal and so forth and that's what
makes sense you get this picture of
these very age
jeans really having dynamics that are
very close related to be ancient
patterns these IP GPS and where the
younger jeans have somewhat different
that are more related to this external
complex
okay so that was discussing a base model
and now we're going to talk a little bit
about logic gates and so now what we
want to do here is we want to sort of
try and see we've talked about looking
at the dynamics with developing these
clusters the ancient clusters new
expression and we've talked about how we
can think about looking at the dynamics
of them you know in terms of these sort
of highly conserved patterns and now we
want to do is think a little bit more
about their control and you know think
about if we can describe their control
and it kind of canonical if so here
we're going to talk about describing the
control in terms of logic gates and so
first I want to introduce the notion of
logic gates and then I want to talk
about how we can apply the logic gates
so a logic gate is shown in the top left
and figures now if you have to
explicitly know regulators in the genes
or Christa's these might come from in
chip seek experiment or something we use
send positive these two factors are 1
and R 2 regulated target T a logic gate
would be well if the two regulators are
on for instance do I see the target
genes off okay it's precedented if you
had an or gate a regulator might one
regulator might be on the other might
view up and you see the charges off if
you had an ad engage man that both
regulators are on and charting to be
honest that would be kind of a kind of
canonical kind of circuits picture of
regulation and you know people are to
something to be fairly comfortable with
this I fix this is a very electrical
circuit type of you and so what we want
to do is see to degree to which we look
at the gene expression patterns of the
regulators going on and off and then the
targets going on off do they fit into
these very understandable logic gates
type of pictures
so we developed this feature we call low
reject for fitting patterns of gene
expression to logic gates and what
you're supposed to see in this figure is
how we keep the Senate seat let's just
look at the top the grid at the top and
what you see there if you see a target
gene that's the bottom row of the grid
and then you see two things that we
pause those regulators and go TF 1 and
tier 2 - transcription factors and then
you see their values their binary values
over 20 samples you know so for instance
in the first thing you see they're all
up and the second one that's stratified
being about you see off on off and then
third one you see on walk law and what
you're you're asked to see if you look
at those patterns like again the lights
in the building is going on a lot do
those patterns tend to fit any of the
patterns you'd expect or a logical gate
okay and so essentially what the figure
shows that we essentially fit the
observed patterns to one of the
canonical logical gates and there's a
kind of canonical truth table there's or
any of these gates that says well that
looks at all the possible input output
combinations and we have how consistent
the gene expression is with one of these
two tables so purses at the bottom you
see the truth table for the an gate and
we can see this particular thing as a
certain consistency with the end gate
using I will possible accession and we
can see that for these two factors and
this target gene they mostly follow the
NBA logic so now what we can do is we
can take our mod one of our model
organism gene expression patterns and we
can see what type of gates are often
used in that and then we've done this
for the worm 5 but I'm actually going to
talk about another model reality simpler
to eat yeast and so what we do in using
the yeast cell cycle which they're very
simple
type of gene expression we have many
potential triplets between regulators
and targets many gene expression points
matter over this cell cycling around we
can see for any given triplet which gate
does it fit for instance if you look at
the first row we have here we have two
potential regulator chains one target
and we have a gate that it tends to
match so we can ask well what gates you
tend to find a lot of people of any age
you've got a lot of or gates and so
forth one of the things that's
interesting is we find a lot of gates
with the cell cycle that seem to be like
and the light gates and so that that
means that that for targeting to go on
we usually require some notion of both
of the regulators to be on now what I'm
going to now to do is show how we've
taken this this idea that we drew out
the model organisms but we're now going
to use this idea to talk about how we
can think about diseases as which of
course is our core idea and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to compare what
we found in the human context to what we
find in a cancer common so there's a
tremendous amount of sort of cancer gene
expression day data and I'm going to
look at a field data set for people of
blood cancer acute myeloid leukemia and
in this context we have you know maybe
200 different patients who are looking
at which genes go kind of on and off in
certain patients and we have a certain
number of no right those are
relationships and one of the things
that's really just immediately you see
when you do this is you get a very
different type of picture of what gates
tend to be used here as opposed to
having n gates you have a preponderance
of or gates used in the leukemia example
and what's really interesting is if I
kind of zoom in and I say I'm only going
to look at
the gates that are have one of the
factors but say the first transcription
factor is Nick now make it a very
well-known regulator that associated
with cancer and it people have written a
lot about in the past and it's you know
Chris I have a little quotation for
paper that Nick is this Universal
amplifier and so with what we're going
to do is we look at all the gates that
involve me and what we see what we do
that is that the not only they tend to
be more like Gates or gates were
completed her mr. gene expression we
just gates term by the value of our one
the pattern is even more intensified
relative to loading so in cancer Jones
you really do the picture of
dysregulation cancer so in the cell
cycle we saw this picture of how we had
to have genes on together to regulate
the cell cycle and cancer we saw well
it's not really like that if one regular
is on it just turns the G on it
regardless the other regular and that is
completely A's for gates involving Mik
which is a transcription factor that's
very associated with the dysregulation
cancer so you can see this kind of
altered written through a circuit usage
in cancer okay so I'm going to keep
going on so now what we've talked about
in the most beginning the talking you
talk about this canonical problem of how
we analyze activity we talked about well
we can look at the activity patterns
among organisms that you can get a sense
how they work and cost of them in the
gates and then we can see to some degree
how we can see different patterns energy
and that's the kind of poor thing we
want to do with our Nasik analysis but
what I'm going to talk about now is just
going to data exhaust issue I'm going to
talk about this idea that actually we're
interested in general conclusions that
we get from looking at these um it says
but actually of course fixing
we're in the awesome human context we're
getting a lot of information not about
things in general but about specific
people and is there a way finding the
specific the general conclusions without
revealing too much about the patient
data this makes this gene expression
data particularly tricky from a privacy
perspective because we want to get
general conclusions from data on
specific individuals and can we do this
without compromising their privacy and I
just want to say a little bit about
genomic privacy you know this is kind of
a big issue that people are talking
about is this notion of genome is this
very fundamental type of data related to
people and you know there's sort of um
that this idea also that it's passed on
through many generations so we have a
privacy breach of a person or of the
updated now it essentially is very
impactful in the future and there's also
cited oh don't know that much about
maybe the genome now but in the future
maybe we'll know a lot more suppose this
idea that we have to be very careful
about this which makes a lot of sense
and there's also this notion that um you
know we have to be particularly careful
with the data but you know there's a lot
of situations where things in genetics
have been used in a very challenged
fashion right before more recent
examples of this is what happens with
the pls cell line content very
controversial and you know we can
reflect that this sort of data sharing
versus privacy concern it's similar to
what we get in other contexts you know
in sense one of the crimes you know
large cell data and data science they
data is how we can aggregate the data
over many individual isn't it really
useful things that you know your Google
web search works so well because Google
aggregates the results of many web
searches over millions of individual
and they can figure out you know how
those individuals are answering
surgeries are clicking search queries in
aggregate and that gives them to say a
way of providing the answer can the
individual person that's better that
they just studied that University of
courses so issue you know compromising
the privacy of the individual people
that are using the things so this
similar issue but it may be it's a
little different because we're dealing
with genomic information not just level
on us or something and there's also this
notion that obviously we have to share
data to speed medical research to help
medical research in a lot of the
restrictions on in sharing in data
mining tend to encumber research and
they also make research less
reproducible and so we kind of have this
these two sides of this coin this sort
of dilemma that we tend to have in
modern research where you know we have
the notion we pool a lot of data
together we can do this fancy mining
that I'm showing in terms of clustering
it and analyzing doing all those things
but we essentially compromise the
individuals privacy so we want to think
about how to balance these two things
and one of the key elements in the
balancing of this notion that it's not a
black and white thing and you know
obviously if you look at a person and
you look at the eye color you're getting
a tiny bit of genetic variants
associated their eye color and people
are you know you can't hide all of our
genetic information yet the notion of
people having all of their variants
available on the web it's maybe a little
extremist we want to have some notion of
how much information is a leak when we
do various calculations when we share
various data set so there are sort of
different modes of doing this currently
and in the current mode of dealing with
a lot of our so it is this notion of
encrypting the data having consent to
use it and sort of locking the data
you know on the computer that using a
lot of these need to get hacked and a
very cumbersome and so forth and the
alternative of course is that all the
data should public you know I think that
there's a lot of people who sort of say
will frequent privacy is not a it's not
meaningful you know it may be out into
the future and that is such a cumbersome
thing and people are happy to share
information this is a good idea it's not
clear that they're going to scale the
very large cohorts groups of people on
so forth and so in any case we what
we've been thinking about is that one of
the key things you need to do to move
forward in the future is to really kind
of develop ways of quantifying
information leakage and experiments and
kind of quantifying what's going on I'm
going to be talking about that now so
I'm going to do that I'm going to use
another gene expression data set this is
called the Jew volleys is and this did
is that is important because I'm like
the other different it's essentially
just a similar to interests is that over
it over about five hundred individuals
to spider images blood gene expression
and we can look at the genes going up
and down and we can relate them to the
variants in these people and that's a
person to make sure we're trying to
protect and the relationship between the
variants on gene expression levels is
called an EQ TF and I'm going to talk
about that effect here and so first I
wanted to just introduce the notion of
the QTL that's shown in this bigger
where you know the the idea is that if
you must have a three different states
for a particular game time you know
reference genotype homozygous reference
homozygous also real or both really also
alternate allele or a heterozygous but
here in the middle and you can imagine
tabulating the G expression for a given
gene relative to that gene genotype and
if there was any QTL you might see a
relationship for instance on the
reference allele might have someone
lower the expression than the alter Li
and you can express that
always stressed to some form of
correlation and we developed some
quantifications of this that are useful
to thinking about privacy so one thing
you can do is while you can express the
relationship as a correlation it's
actually better to express it in
information theoretic terms and so we've
involved this notion of expressing the
gene expression relationship as a
conditional entropy so get given the
gene expression given you have ingenuity
expression what is your your condition
entropy is that less or it is that less
or more than if you didn't know the gene
expression and obviously the lower the
lower the entropy the higher predictable
is so we have this notes of the
explanation at initiation on this
conditional entropy is a way of more
precisely describing how gene expression
is predictable of the geofence and also
this description that knowledge
genotypes are equal if you know say a
very person's genotype very common snip
that they after people have a population
you know less information than if you
know versus genotype for very rare so if
you putzes know that a person has a very
rare variant you know more about that
person than if you know they have to
keep their commoner and so we developed
this relation also for that individual
characterizing information I CI which
basically one over the logarithm of the
frequency of genotype so where are
genotypes get more character information
and one of the nice things about these
information VI
quantities is that you can add the
amount of characterizing which to
assuming the genotypes between two
things that you're a member and the
conditions just in case but if they're
independent if you
- e-commerce information is leaked by
leaking a certain number genotypes you
simply just add up the iti each sentence
essentially adding up the number of some
degrees adding a bit of the rare snips
and then what we can do with these two
points you can ask ourselves how much
information is linked in gene expression
experiments you know if you know all the
eqtls in a person you can ask well how
predictable of those booty ELLs
and the underlying variants relates
those in detail how characterizing come
to us dialing feature and obviously you
tend to get the more leakage you get
from a synth that you know it allows us
that usually it becomes less predictable
in terms of frequency expression
elationship there's a caramel download
correlation but there's a few ETL as you
can see that are they're both highly
predictable yet they will also be tend
to leave a lot of information and those
of course but those details are ones
that would be most keen to kind of
filter out protecting someone's privacy
and we can you know if an app you know
we find the best eqtl in gene expression
experiment on how much we should have we
can say if we take the two best details
and sort of add their ability together
you know how much leakage we have we
just add their i CI and then their three
best and so forth then we have how many
bits of information to leak anything key
point is that with just a few gene
expression levels better validity
details we actually leak we can
depreciable onto variant information and
this is you know kind of theoretical
idea but we sort of practically see it
could potentially be worrisome and so in
relations this week
kind of developed this narrative
actually exploiting this to do what's
called linking attack and the idea here
is that we have our publicly available
gene expression data set that's the
thing on the left where people just put
gene expression levels that we think are
kind of anonymized that do not have
their innate information gene expression
data might be related to particular
condition ones cancer or not on having
HIV not and so forth and we have the
notion of the that we think this
information is kind of an anonymous and
so forth we have this notion of get
group of genotypes maybe we could
actually connect someone's genotype
stuff to people
anonymized data set and then potentially
find out if a person had a
characteristic gene expression pattern
or say having HIV Grammys let's see and
this is fairly related to the famous tag
that recently happened for the Netflix
attack and it's called that it's a type
of attack for the linking attack and the
basic idea and this attack is that
Netflix which disabilities the viewing
habits of many individuals you know
because they had a non-ahmadi username
people and they had a servant down the
fire while moving a watch and a
particular date you might think that
this is a very anonymous data set of
what people were able to show is that
another database IMDB had identify
double people that viewed a move movies
out of paper or day and you could
actually by studying the dates and the
entries consideration can make a
connection between some rows in this the
IMDB database and some entries in the
Netflix database now the key thing is
there's no real private information loss
to make mechanism people have already
revealed in the IMDB database that thing
and watch a good movie energy per day
but now you know that anonymous
individual and the Netflix is that this
man you can see maybe there's another
movie that personal wants to influence
report in the
and in this way you by linking the two
databases together you've actually do
not mock the network business and so
that's actually exactly what we're doing
in this linking attack what we do here
is we show how we can link these two
databases the public phenotype data set
which is essentially like the necklace
they send them this stolen or hat
genotype on it is that we can share how
we can make it connection between the
two and the way we do that is through
inverting the qtls to essentially take
the the gene special levels in the
public cleaners identity and du chien
type prediction that's a very noisy
error-prone jin-tae predictions and you
killed but the key thing isn't even
though it's noisy it's done in a fairly
large scale so that we can still make
some matches clicking with the genotype
on the database we can still get an
approximate linking or connection once
we establish that one here connection we
can determine which which individual say
parcel is particular to express
measurement and then get the private
information of what type of conditions
they have and we you know we show that
you can do this with variety of
inversion strategies which is a
prediction you might it's not obvious I
just will show you a very simple types
of conversions you can do this and I'm
learning a little bit about time so I'm
just going to say we can demonstrate
that actually this attack will you can
actually determine you then leave a lot
of the people business in deg biases
which you really know they're been even
if he did determine it fairly relative a
fairly obvious I'm going to just quickly
get there and just summarize what we
talked I'm gonna leave out the left
business topper let me just so I could
jump so what I've tried to talk to you
about
today is kind of what we do in
transcriptome analysis and what I wanted
to talk to us comes the core way we
analyze the activity panels of genes
going on in model organisms and also by
individuals and you know the core thing
we want to do is you know make sense of
these patterns of genes on offer much
like the lights and the building's going
on and you know one thing you can do
with us is clustering that's
traditionally what's been stolen all
together and I've showed you how we can
develop earth fighting once again the
clustering approach what we consistently
cluster genes and say two different
organisms or three different organisms
to get these very conservative models of
gene expression say between 100 plus on
60 modules that are very loyal to
development and then the next thing is
we try to understand what are the
modules working independently or they
coupled to something else and to do that
use this notion about States based
models where we try to see if we can
describe the dynamics of these modules
kind of independently in terms of module
themselves or they have to be cold and
so now to use this base base model or
course they may look part of what main
premise we have to produce the dimension
system and think about not genes but
these kind of meta genes and when we do
that we can solve sort of state space
equations and we can see that the gene
expression in these safer McFly's
organisms we describe in terms of Nala
metagenes that these sort of internal
dynamic patterns and so from these and
the internal dynamic patterns these two
organisms are very similar and they're
actually even more similar for very
conserved in ancient genes than they are
or more recent genes so you get the
sense that be on the inside of these
under conserved expression all modules
is these internal dynamic patents are
very ancient gene expression patterns
you know conical rise for America
oscillation and then I talked about
how cool interpret happens the
expression in terms of making logical
models for activity and here I try to
use this logic gave us a type of engine
seemed to fit
particularly logic gates to have as a
gene expression going on awful you can
see that the maintaining season is that
we look at a normal side of the process
like the cell cycle or something you see
we have a very awesome very tightly
control process that involves odd and
gates where we looked at various
regulate process we seen disease cancer
we see it's a very different type of
regulation involved when we need for
debates so that's the kind of picture
like what are we doing in gene
expression in office how do people make
sense of activity patterns what are they
doing and then in the second part of the
talk I want to say well jeez you know
when they're doing this on basic
analysis fit with our allies and even
samples there this kind of data drops
there's the identity of these people and
there's their privacy potentially being
colorized and I wanted to sort of think
about that it's a very different type of
thing and I sort of talked about a
little bit of the dilemma of this
gentleman privacy you know how we really
want to protect patient privacy at the
same time we need to do very large scale
mining to do the things that we talked
about the first half and so I talked a
little bit how we think about this and
you know I think one of the key ideas
that can really think it was a blessing
why problem you can have told I've seen
looking you have a lot of total exposure
you really have to think about how much
information leaks and I tried to explain
how you might think about that in terms
of rna-seq how much information is
leaked imaging experiments from it and
that is really bleakest through these eq
tails relationship gene expression to
various disease gels you know quantify
it and also metrics like this i seei or
predictability to talk about that and
then i talked about practically can you
use the leaked information to kind of
hack into a publishing expressionism JFS
public can use a small amount of public
information to potentially notify people
i show actually a confirmation has done
so with that I think I'll conclude I
didn't talk about that last thing I was
maybe gonna talk about which the
publication patterns well I think that
was enough for today and I'll just
conclude by acknowledging the people
that work on this so the the most of the
gene expression dynamics was really done
by two individuals in my lab I think
Wang and Koo Kien subtyping worked on
these now correct which is the state
based models and the lower edge of
pelagic 18 let those analyses and who
you are was done cuckoo yawn or Tommy
clustering evil folk custom asses URLs I
will stop there and the privacy analysis
and was really known by another
associate research scientist a rift
Comanche who solved this could it be
cute child English or was my wisdom I'm
your house there and so forth might
appreciate my attention questions thank
you dr. Thurston for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to add to do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
second button on the send button will
enter as many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started our
first question is do you think that
issues of genomic privacy will be a
practical major impediment of research
and the future do you think this is a
very big movie business do you think
this is a very big issue
you know of course the promise of
genomics is that were going to be doing
this on a very very very large scale
over potentially millions people a large
chunk of the population and of course
get those
full value genomics which is ability to
do positive things we have to either get
all this data together and come up with
a jet more general conclusions from it
and I think everyone agrees that that's
the promise but first to do that
appropriately we have to ensure the
individuals that are donating their data
that they privacy is protected that the
aggregation of all of this information
will not compromise their privacy and so
I think this and you know it may be seen
Bobby say we will encrypt the data or
we'll keep it on business or what I've
tried to show today but it's actually
much more subtle on you hasn't found out
repeatedly it's very large is that this
subtle ways is that leaked information
and we have to think about this
carefully will release of our drugs
information and really develop
formalisms for measuring information
leakage
okay we have time for one more question
you think that transcriptional modules
are associated with certain
characteristic types of logical date
good question it's something we haven't
that's a good question it's something we
haven't completely worked through but
you know we're very interested those
particular types of modules that we've
shown that there's just the genes go up
and down in a coordinated way to
different organisms you know they're
associated with different characteristic
internal dynamics you know I didn't
focus on detail but there also tend to
be associated in different functions and
it'd be very interesting to see if they
were they had fundamentally different
regulatory structure maybe one is more a
couple then more regulated by Saint Ann
gates
than another one which is more organ so
we haven't been able to disentangle this
that this is something that we would see
in a direction to go in the future
I would like to once again thank dr.
mark garrison for its presentation I
would also like to thank laberd's for
making space educational mark as
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August 11 2017 you'll receive an
email from Laxus letting you know that
when this webcast will be available for
research make sure that announcement
lizard colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again
goodbye